WAI CHEE DIMOCK: So we'll
get started
on The Great Gatsby.
I'm sure that you guys have your
own views on the novel.
So what I'll be talking about
today is in some sense a more
focused or sharp-edged take on
Gatsby, which you're certainly
free to dispute in section.
But I want to begin with
Maxwell Perkins.
And his name actually came up
last time when Fitzgerald read
the In Our Time stories, the
Paris edition, the person he
wrote to was Maxwell Perkins
to say that he's the real
thing, you have to get him.
So Maxwell Perkins, obviously
very, very important.
I would say that he really
is the muse of the 1920s.
So the muse doesn't have to be
a woman, doesn't have to be a
romantic relation.
He's just a very, very good
reader, careful reader,
critical reader, as we'll see.
And this is a book about Maxwell
Perkins and his three
sons, Fitzgerald on the left,
Hemingway in the middle, and
Thomas Wolfe on the right.
And these people wrote
to him constantly.
He really was their mentor and
muse to all three of them.
And so Hemingway and Fitzgerald
have that
in common as well.
It's great to have an
editor that you're
both responding to.
So anyway, Maxwell Perkins was
the one who read the initial
drafts of The Great Gatsby,
and this is what he said
November 20, 1924.
"Gatsby is somewhat vague.
The reader's eyes can never
quite focus upon him.
His outlines are dim.
Now everything about Gatsby is
more or less a mystery, i.e.,
more or less vague, and this may
be somewhat of an artistic
intention, but I think
it is mistaken.
Couldn't he be physically
described as distinctly as the
others, and couldn't you add
one or two characteristics
like the use of that phrase 'old
sport,' not verbal, but
physical ones, perhaps?"
So very upfront about what he
likes, and in this case, what
he doesn't like.
And he's also giving us
the terminology, loose
terminology, vague and
loose, to think
about The Great Gatsby.
And this is what Fitzgerald
says back in turn
December 20, 1924.
"Strange to say my notion of
Gatsby as vacant was OK.
This is a complicated idea,
but I'm sure you'll
understand.
I know Gatsby better than
I know my own child.
My first instinct after your
letter was to let him go and
have Tom Buchanan dominate
the book.
But Gatsby sticks in my heart.
I had him for a while, then
lost him, and now I know I
have him again."
You can't have a better
description of an author's
relation to his creation.
And I think that this is
actually probably quite
common, the feeling that you
know this character better
than you know your
family members.
But in this case, also being
quite deliberate and stubborn
in not giving in to Maxwell
Perkins' suggestion that he
should make Gatsby less vague.
And one other quote from
Fitzgerald to Perkins.
This is much later, in 1940.
"I wish I was in print.
It would be odd a year or so
from now when Scottie"--
his daughter--
"assures her friends I was an
author and finds that no book
is procurable.
Will the $0.25 press keep Gatsby
in the public eye, or
is the book unpopular?
Has it had its chance?
But to die so completely
and unjustly after
having given so much.
Even now, there is little
published in American fiction
that doesn't slightly
bear my stamp.
In a small way, I was
an original."
It's really heartbreaking that
Fitzgerald in fact never knew
that The Great Gatsby would
become the kind of
book that it is.
He would be totally
flabbergasted.
His idea was that this was
something that would just
completely disappear.
So I think that we
can see several
things from this exchange.
First is that Fitzgerald really
didn't know how this
book was going to end up.
So it's completely a matter of
hindsight that we are able to
say now that this is the
American classic.
He didn't know that it wasn't
a classic back then.
It was experimental.
So we shouldn't lose
sight of that fact.
It was an experiment, and he
really didn't know if it was
going to come out well or not.
In fact, his hunch in 1940 was
that it was going to be a
failure, that it was going to
go nowhere; that it wasn't
going to be picked up by anyone,
that all this effort,
so much given to the
novel, all that was
going to come to nothing.
So I think that this in itself
suggests to us the
experimental nature, that he was
trying something new and
because we're so used to it now,
in some sense, it stops
being new to us.
So it's very important to go
back to that original sense of
things being in flux and not
being sure if this was the way
things were going to go.
The other interesting point
about this letter is that
Fitzgerald said that, "In a
small way, I was an original."
So this is not actually
modesty.
I think that he's very proud of
the fact that in a small--
well, no, it is modesty too.
But I think that he's also
taking pride in the fact that
his greatness resides in his
smallness, that it's really in
the small details of The Great
Gatsby that he would most like
to be read.
So we are very much operating
on the micro register today,
respecting Fitzgerald's
sense of what kind of
an author he was.
And what I'd like
to do today--
this is basically the outline
for today's lecture--
is to take the terminology
from Maxwell Perkins--
"vagueness"--
and use a slightly more formal
term and also stretching it a
little bit.
So the term that I'd like to
propose for us to consider
today is a synonym for
"vagueness," is
"counter-realism." We know that
there's a lot that is
realistic in The Great Gatsby,
but there's also a strain of
counter-realism.
And maybe that's why it gives
the impression of being vague.
And I'd like to tease out some
of the attributes or
manifestations of the
counter-realist mode of writing.
First of all--
and I'll explain all this--
but there's some desire to
capture motion.
This is actually something that
was done in 19th-century
photography, daguerreotype,
trying to capture motion.
This was started actually very
much by using machines and the
early camera to capture
motion.
And I think that Fitzgerald
was trying to do something
like that in The Great Gatsby.
Another component of this
counter-realism is the
uncertain boundaries between the
animate and the inanimate,
and related to that, human
attributes, properties of
human personalities or
properties of the human body
being channeled or
routed through
properties of the machine.
And then going back to our
discussion of comedy and
tragedy, there's a variety of
high-tech comedy and a variety
of high-tech tragedy in this
novel, but they're also
interconnected.
So let's first look at what
Fitzgerald is trying to do in
capturing motion.
But I thought that I would just
give you a completely
static image of the mansion.
This is the Guggenheim
Mansion.
Merve actually mentioned that
she went to a wedding there.
STUDENT: My senior prom.
PROFESSOR: Your senior prom.
And so you can go and visit.
But this is the Guggenheim
Mansion, so it's over-the-top.
But this is the nature of those
mansions at Sand's Point
or East Egg, where Tom
and Daisy live.
And so this is a very static--
very impressive but static
image of a mansion.
Let's see how Fitzgerald
describes
that Buchanan mansion.
"The lawn started at the beach
and ran toward the front lawn
for a quarter of a mile, jumping
over sun-dials and
brick walls and burning
gardens--
finally when it reached the
house drifting up the side in
bright vines as though from
the momentum of its run."
It's completely not a static
description at all.
There's a little bit of static
description of what the house
looks like, but I think this is
really what jumps out at us
is the translation of a static
physical object into motion.
This is not even trying to
capture something that is
actually moving but trying to
attribute motion to something
that is otherwise stationary
and static.
And this is quite early, so
we don't quite know why
Fitzgerald would choose
to write in this way.
But definitely, this is a very,
very deliberate way of
writing, so make sure to keep
that in mind is that there's
quite often a kind
of conversion.
Conversion takes place all
the time in Fitzgerald.
We've seen that he converts
qualities of
sound into visual images.
And he also converts stationary
objects into moving objects.
So there's a quality that's
certainly more dynamic.
But it also gives a sense that
even right here, we can say
that it's almost as if
the lawn has agency.
It's not just sitting there.
It's not just a lawn that
is mowed by someone.
It starts somewhere, it goes
someplace, it jumps over
things, it generates
its own momentum.
So the least we can say is that
inanimate objects have
life and motion and agency.
And that has tremendous
implications both for those
inanimate objects and possibly
also for animate objects, like
human beings.
When you have inanimate
objects taking on the
properties of animate human
beings, what happens to human
beings, who are supposedly
in possession of those
properties?
So this is just a very--
this is not a dramatic moment,
but it says a lot about the
strategy that Fitzgerald uses.
So let's go on now and look more
at the boundaries between
the animate and the inanimate,
because I think that this is
really a major strategy
performed
throughout The Great Gatsby.
So this is an image of Corona,
which is the original for the
Valley of Ashes that
Fitzgerald describes somewhere.
Just this no-man's land,
even in this very
desolate visual image.
But still we can visualize
such a place,
desolate as it is.
Let's look at the
way Fitzgerald
describes this place.
"About halfway between West Egg
and New York, the motor
road hastily joins the railroad
and runs beside it
for a quarter of a mile, so as
to shrink away from a certain
desolate area of land.
This is a valley of ashes--
a fantastic farm where ashes
grow like wheat into ridges
and hills and grotesque gardens,
where ashes take the
forms of houses and chimneys and
rising smoke and, finally,
with a transcendent effort of
men who move dimly and already
crumbling through
the powdery air.
Occasionally, a line of grey
cars crawls along an invisible
track, gives out a ghastly
creak, and comes to rest, and
immediately the ash-grey men
swarm up with leaden spades
and stir up an impenetrable
cloud, which screens their
obscure operations
from your sight."
I honestly don't know what
Fitzgerald is talking about,
whether he's really talking
about actual ash-grey men.
Who are those men?
They don't look like people
who work at gas stations.
We just don't know
what they are.
So by the time we get to the
end of the passage, the
ontological status of the
passage is really in doubt.
We don't know if this is just
hallucination, if this is an
optical illusion, or something
even worse than that, a
hallucination on the
part of Nick.
So we can now see the fact that
inanimate objects have
agency and are capable of
moving, that they tend to
render the visual field very
wobbly, very shaky.
It's quite often out of focus.
Quite often, it's like a camera
that is moving, this
blurry image.
So we don't exactly know
what we're looking at.
But even though we can't exactly
say, we can name the
thing that we're looking at.
There is something grotesque
about this scene, and the
grotesqueness comes
not so much from
the landscape itself.
In the original landscape, it's
just sad, but it's not
especially grotesque.
The grotesqueness comes really
completely from Fitzgerald's
rhetoric, from his rhetorical
intensification of that
landscape.
Ashes growing like wheat and
into ridges and hills and
grotesque gardens, ashes taking
the form of houses, and
so on, and maybe ashes turning
into those ash-grey men, maybe
they're just optical illusions,
that they're not
really biological
human beings.
We don't know.
So it seems as if there's
a grotesque fecundity to
inanimate objects.
Ashes are capable
of reproduction.
They are capable of reproducing
themselves in a
way that we tend to think that
only animate things are
capable of doing.
Reproduction is not a property,
is not a prerogative
of inanimate objects.
But here, it seems as if it
actually is within the
province of inanimate objects
to be grotesquely
reproductive.
So already what we're beginning
to see is the
writing-over of a lot of the
things that we had imagined to
be on the human side
of the equation.
All those things that we have
that are in our possession
that we are the sole owners of,
all those things are being
written over to inanimate
objects that might or might
not be benign to us.
Because we don't really know
what the relation is between
these inanimate objects
and us.
But I think there's yet another
twist to this passage,
and it has to do with a very
unobtrusive but I would say
nontrivial phrase, which is "the
motor road hastily joins
the railroad and runs beside it
for a quarter of a mile."
Do you guys remember anything,
hearing that phrase before?
"The lawn started at the beach
and ran toward the front lawn
for a quarter of a mile." So
this is the verbal echo, a
very small but telling detail
that suggests that those two
passages are connected.
We can really see what
a craftsman he is, a
genius in a small way.
But that's why he's so great
is that it's just this
completely seemingly factual
phrasing that serves as the
bond between those
two passages.
So the suggestion would seem to
be that there's kind of an
underside to the Buchanan
garden, grand mansion, and on
and so on, that this is
really the underside.
And in fact, the two of them
actually have a lot in common.
There's a lot of
common ground.
And the life, the strange and
obscure but very fertile and
menacing life of the inanimate
object would seem to be the
common ground between
those two.
So we don't have to read very
far into Great Gatsby to know
that there's something very
wrong with that marriage
between Tom and Daisy.
And the landscape itself suggest
that the desolation is
never really absent from
that household.
So I know that we are all
thinking about Gatsby because
really Maxwell Perkins objected
mostly to the
portrait of Gatsby, that
he's very vague.
So here is this 1974
version embodied by
Robert Redford of Gatsby.
And I have to say, when
I see this, it's not--
I wouldn't say it's not not my
image of Gatsby, but it's also
not my image of Gatsby either,
because I really haven't
really visualized Gatsby
all that much.
So I have a funny relation
to this.
It's OK, but I guess I really
could do without him.
But anyway, it is an interesting
foil to what
Fitzgerald is trying to
do, because I don't--
certainly we should see the
movie and everything, but the
book is trying to do something
very different.
He's not trying to
create a Robert
Redford-like image of Gatsby.
So this is why Maxwell Perkins
thinks that Gatsby is vague.
"If personality is an unbroken
series of successful gestures,
then there was something
gorgeous about him, some
heightened sensitivity to the
promises of life, as if he
were related to one of those
intricate machines that
register earthquakes
10,000 miles away."
There is almost no physical
description.
This is very early-- it's true,
we haven't seen Gatsby--
but there really is never
a full-fledged physical
description of Gatsby.
And instead, we get these
very, very oblique, very
abstract descriptions of Gatsby
telling us about his
personality, but not even
supplying us with adjectives
to name that.
So we can just look at the
simple level of syntax.
Its heading is circuitous.
It's in the conditional tense.
"If"-- begins with
the word "if"--
"If personality is an unbroken
series." So right there, it's
not even a declarative
sentence.
It's a conditional sentence,
"if" and "then" construction.
So Nick is not even fully
committing himself to that
description.
He's holding back
to some degree.
And not only that, not only
is this very obtrusive
conditionality to the syntax,
but then out of nowhere,
there's this description that
he's related to this machine,
seismograph machine that
"register earthquakes 10,000
miles away." It really isn't a
very vivid analogy at all.
It's not a graphic analogy.
Gatsby does not look
in the least like
that kind of machine.
We don't know what he looks
like, but we know for sure he
doesn't look like one
of those machines.
So it is not an analogy
that's helping us
to visualize Gatsby.
And quite the contrary, it's
making it-- so that's why I
think that the movie is
really its own entity.
It's not really related
to the book.
It's a totally different
medium.
This is the linguistic medium
that Fitzgerald is working
with and is trying to do
something different.
And I have to say, it
is an open question.
Some of us actually are more
stimulated by the visual
medium than by the linguistic
medium.
So I'm not saying here
that the movie is
inferior to the novel.
But I do think that we have to
be sure to give the linguistic
medium its due, in the sense
that it really is trying to do
something different.
So we don't know what Gatsby is
like, other than that he is
someone who seems to be
working with great--
be able to work with great
distances, register an
earthquake 10,000 miles away.
That is really not a skill or
talent that is necessary in
The Great Gatsby.
There are no earthquakes
in The Great Gatsby.
But there is something that
calls for a long-distance
tenacity and persistence, which
is actually across time,
being able to be faithful
to one idea.
So it's not 10,000 miles away
but over a number of years
remaining stubbornly attached
to that one idea of a woman.
So right there, there's also
a substitution or a
transposition of a temporal
attribute onto a spatial
attribute as well.
But in any case, by not
completely pinning Gatsby
down, I think that Fitzgerald
is really inviting us to
project our own meaning or
project our own reading of
Gatsby into this very, very
loosely assembled, very
pointed, but oddly enough,
pointed but not focused.
It's a paradox.
But I think that that's really
the effect that Fitzgerald is
trying to cultivate.
So we spent quite a bit of time
talking about comedy and
tragedy last couple
of classes.
And I want to bring those back
and talk a little bit, once
again, about them as a mixture,
that they are not two
very discrete genres
in the three
authors that we are reading.
They tend to be very much
cross-over genres
in The Great Gatsby.
And here, because machines are
so important in this novel,
comedy is quite often channeled
through high-tech gadgets.
And here is one very
local, very--
basically just-right-there
instance of comedy.
"Every Friday five crates of
oranges and lemons arrived
from a fruiterer in New York.
Every Monday these same oranges
and lemons left his
back door in a pyramid
of pulpless halves.
There was a machine in the
kitchen which could extract
the juice of 200 oranges in
half an hour if a little
button was pressed 200 times
by a butler's thumb."
So I think that Fitzgerald
is having fun with this.
This is comedy both as it comes
to us but also comedy in
the act of composition.
This is obviously an author
who's having a good time
writing about this.
So the reduction of the butler
to just his thumb and the
thumb reduced once more to
a completely utilitarian
function of pressing this button
200 times in half an
hour and producing the effect
on our oranges.
So this is hilarious.
I guess it's terrible if we
think about it from the
butler's point of view, that
this is what he has to do.
But maybe it's repetitive,
monotonous, terrible labor,
really, if we think that that's
what we have to do.
But as Fitzgerald is telling
the story, it's really not
supposed to be tragic.
It is comic, although I would
say that the tragedy or at
least the phenomenon of just
unbearable, repetitive labor
is actually not so far
away from it either.
That is the nature
of comedy here.
So we'll move on.
That little machine, even though
it's memorable, it's
not a star player in
The Great Gatsby.
The telephone is
a star player.
And this is an image of just
what the telephone-- very
glamorous-looking machine,
very beautiful.
So you can see why people would
want to write works of
literature about such
a beautiful machine.
You guys know I'm going to talk
about that phone ringing
when the Buchanans are having
dinner, so we'll get there.
But for now, I just want to have
a little detour by way of
the great poet who mostly is
known for his writing about
nature and is not known for his
writing about technology,
Robert Frost. But Robert Frost
actually has a poem called
"The Telephone." And I think
it's a very, very useful
counterpoint, actually,
to Fitzgerald.
And you'll see whether
he's really
talking about a telephone.
The title of the poem is "The
Telephone." And quite often in
Frost is this is a dramatic
dialogue.
It's a dialogue between
two people.
"Having found the flower
and driven the bee
away, I leaned my head.
And holding by the stalk, I
listened and I thought I
caught the word --
What was it?
Did you call me by my name?
Or did you say--
Someone said, 'Come'--
I heard it as I bowed.
I may have thought as
much, but not aloud.
Well, so I came."
So it's a lovely poem, and it's
a love poem about two
people who are in love.
We don't know the gender,
actually, but I think it's a
man and a woman.
It's someone really wanting to
see someone and just finding
an excuse to come and see that
person and claiming that he's
hearing a voice telling
him to come.
And that is the telephone,
in big quotation marks.
Frost, he knows about the
telephone, but he's really not
talking about the machine.
He's talking about the
impalpable audible bond or the
bond of audibility that just
brings one person to the
presence of another person.
And that is the telephone line,
it is that emotional
cord that really binds
one person.
And that is the most powerful
telephone line of all.
So it's a lovely poem, and it's
very much humanizing the
telephone, turning it into an
emotional, romantic context
charged with human emotions.
And it's really the fact that
it's the carrier of human
emotions that makes the
telephone such an important
human vehicle.
It has been completely
assimilated into the everyday
world of just human intimacy.
So let's see what Fitzgerald
does with the telephone.
"The telephone rang inside,
startlingly, and as Daisy
shook her head decisively at
Tom, the subject of the
stables, in fact all subjects,
vanished into air.
Among the broken fragments of
the last five minutes at
table, I remember the candles
being lit again, pointlessly,
and I was conscious of wanting
to look squarely at everyone,
and yet to avoid all eyes.
I couldn't guess what Daisy and
Tom were thinking, but I
doubt if even Miss Baker, who
seemed to have mastered a
certain hardy skepticism, was
able to put this fifth guest's
shrill metallic urgency
out of mind."
So on the other end of the
spectrum from Robert Frost,
surprisingly, actually.
Because he's on the other
side of the spectrum.
Actually, the telephone actually
is also charged with
intense emotions.
This is not just a machine.
So we can almost always say
that machines are always
carriers of human emotions
in one way or another.
And that's why they're
important machines.
If they were just like that
button that the butler presses
with his thumb, it wouldn't
be a very
important presence at all.
But the telephone is a very
important presence in The
Great Gatsby.
And what's interesting about
this particular scenario
constructed around this
high-tech machine in the 1920s
is the association of this
high-tech machine with an
intrusive force into a
traditional household.
Before the telephone rang,
it was a pleasant dinner.
And Daisy and Tom and her
cousin, Nick, and good friend,
Jordan Baker, are all
sitting down to a
very civilized dinner.
And in the course of that
civilized dinner, suddenly,
the appearance of barbarian
hordes that was mentioned by
Tom, because he's reading this
book about The Rise of the
Colored Empires.
So there's the first intrusion
of somebody not wanted, but
not quite dismissible.
That is not a trivial reference,
because actually
Daisy then picks it up and
talks about her white
girlhood and so on.
So The Rise of the Colored
Empires by Goddard that Tom
has been reading, that
actually is the first
intrusive, uninvited guest. It's
just a book, but it very
much was an uninvited
guest to the dinner.
And then there's a second
uninvited guest coming by way
of the telephone.
So we can say there's a causal
relation between them.
It's not as if the telephone is
always bringing in people
from a different social
class, really.
And we know later that Myrtle,
who's calling here, is of such
a unacceptable social class.
Even though she's OK as a
mistress, it's not OK for her
to mention Daisy's name.
When she mentions Daisy's name,
Tom breaks her nose.
So that is the taboo
that Tom would not
allow Myrtle to break.
Someone like her has no right
to mention his wife's name.
That comes later.
Right now, all we know is that
there's a lot of malice on the
part of Myrtle.
If you want to talk to someone
discreetly, you don't call
during dinnertime.
So it was a call that comes
bearing malice to begin with
and is met with--
well, malice or just the luxury
of being able to ignore
her, which is the freedom that
Daisy and Tom are summoning at
this moment.
So all the social antagonisms
that are bubbling, actually,
beneath the surface of The
Great Gatsby, all those
antagonisms are being
foregrounded by virtue of this
high-tech machine.
And we also shouldn't forget,
The Great Gatsby is not a book
about race.
We have to be very careful that,
even though there's a
reference to Rise of the Colored
Empires, it's not
primarily about race.
But race is also not unimportant
in The Great
Gatsby, which is very,
very strange to me.
Somebody should write a paper
about this, beginning with the
reference to Rise of the
Colored Empires.
There's actually a persistent
undercurrent of blackness,
actually, in this novel.
So there also is a kind
of undercurrent of
[? Germanism, ?]
that Gatsby is supposed to be in
the pay of the German army.
He's supposed to be a cousin
of the Kaiser.
All of those are really, really
peculiar and quite insistent.
So as you go on to write papers,
something to notice.
These very marginal references,
they are not trivial.
So let's look now at really
the star player, the star
high-tech player who's going to
be the star player all the
way through The Great Gatsby,
which is the car.
And we should call it
automobile, because it's a
more dignified name.
So here's the automobile.
And this is the 1920s
Rolls-Royce.
And this actually is a pretty
good representation, or at
least this is the car that was
used in The Great Gatsby.
And we see Nick and
Gatsby there.
Sam Waterston is Nick,
Robert Redford.
So it looks very much
like that car.
And to get a better view
of the Rolls-Royce--
sorry, all respect for the
Rolls-Royce, but this doesn't
seem like a very impressive
vehicle.
I can work up some excitement
about it, but I wouldn't say
it's really that stunning.
Sorry.
It looks more stunning with
human beings in it.
But on the whole,
it's just a car.
But here is Fitzgerald's
description of the
Rolls-Royce.
"I had seen it.
Everybody had seen it.
It was a rich cream color,
bright with nickel, swollen
here and there in its monstrous
length with
triumphant hat-boxes and
supper-boxes and tool-boxes,
and terraced with a labyrinth of
wind-shields that mirror a
dozen suns.
Sitting down behind many layers
of glass in a sort of
green leather conservatory,
we started to town."
This is not a description
of that car.
No.
This is pure fabrication
on Fitzgerald's part.
And there's a reference
back to classical
mythology to a labyrinth.
I don't know what car would
have a "labyrinth of
wind-shields." So it seems that
Fitzgerald is not really
talking about a car so much as
just an occasion to use the
classical mythology.
And this is, in fact, the
stuff that modern
mythology is made of.
This is the car.
It's the heart and soul
of modern mythology.
And it's high-tech mythology
that this is what enables us
to create myths about ourselves
and about other
human beings that we
are intrigued by.
So in many ways, this is
Nick's tribute to this
completely mysterious and
seemingly superhuman person--
or not superhuman in the way
that he's better than all of
us, but in the sense that he's
not quite human, both maybe
subhuman and superhuman
combined, that there's
something about him that he's
just not like the rest of us.
And so as a consequence of
Gatsby not being quite like
the rest of us, his car also
has to be not quite like
anything else on
Earth, really.
It has to be basically this
creature of language.
But what is also interesting is
that there's a gesture or
an attempt to go back, actually,
to that original
image of the Valley of Ashes and
the grotesque fecundity of
the ashes, inanimate objects
capable of reproduction.
Here, the car is a "green
leather conservatory." We
don't know what vegetation
is in that conservatory.
It could be that it is not--
obviously, it's not
real vegetation.
It is whatever is growing
in Gatsby's heart.
Something has to be growing
there in order for it to
survive all those years.
And oddly enough, whatever is
growing there can be preserved
and nourished only by high-tech
machines that he really--
Gatsby is very much a self-made
man, and he's also
self-making a particular kind
of romantic relation.
But the nourishment that that
kind of self-making needs is
actually high-tech sustenance,
high-tech maintenance and
high-tech sustenance.
So in all those ways, we can
see that the inanimate has
taken over and is really
contributing and shaping the
human world.
I want to end with two more
images of the automobile.
And this is looking ahead.
And the first one is a very
marginal and not especially
noticeable detail that I think
that we should, in fact, try
to notice and try to
do something with.
This is when Nick is going
to New York with Tom.
"A dead man passed us in a
hearse heaped with blooms,
followed by two carriages with
drawn blinds, and by more
cheerful carriages
for friends.
As we crossed Blackwell's
Island, a limousine passed us,
driven by a white chauffeur,
in which sat three modish
negroes, two bucks,
and a girl.
I laughed aloud as the yolks
of their eyeballs rolled
toward us in haughty rivalry."
This is really what I mean by
race being a very unexpected
undercurrent in The
Great Gatsby.
This really is a completely
unnecessary detail.
We'll never see that limousine
driven by the white chauffeur
with the two black men and
a young black woman
sitting in that car.
It's the reversal of the iconic
image of what skin
color the chauffeur usually is
of and the skin color of the
people who are usually sitting
in the limousine.
So a complete reversal
of the color
scheme inside a limousine.
But even though that's a
striking visual detail, it is
not necessary.
There's no obvious
necessity for its
placement in the novel.
So this is one instance
where something is--
I would say it is
under-determined in the sense
that the passage right there,
and in fact the rest of the
novel, is not giving us an
adequate explanation.
Under-determined, not enough
information is given to us to
enable us to make sense
of this particular
moment in the novel.
The only way we can make
sense of it is through
interpretation.
So interpretation is actually a
necessary link in order for
this passage to make
sense, to be an
organic part of the novel.
So I would argue that in some
sense, race is being adduced
sometimes as a visual analog
to people crossing class
boundaries, that there's
something--
this is an act of transgression
or a reversal of
social hierarchy.
Myrtle intruding into the dinner
of her social betters--
and I'm using that phrase
deliberately.
That has to be in
quotation marks.
But the offense, part of the
offense of Myrtle is that she
really should stick to her
social station and stick to
her place, and she's intruding
into this private space of her
social betters.
And in some sense, this is the
same kind of transgression or
intrusion or reversal of the
traditional hierarchies in the
three African-Americans being
driven by a white chauffeur.
So all of that is almost as if
Fitzgerald can't really talk
about it in terms of Gatsby,
who's actually the person
who's most responsible for that
kind of transgression.
And Gatsby is really related
to Myrtle in that way.
When thinking about who gets
killed at the end of the
novel, that is one bond between
Gatsby and Myrtle.
But there are numerous other
bonds between them, and race,
a kind of oblique racial
transposition actually is one
of the common grounds between
Gatsby and Myrtle.
So this is a very intriguing
moment in The Great Gatsby.
And this is just to round up
what we know, the plot of The
Great Gatsby.
I don't think I'm giving
anything away.
This is actually the moment when
Fitzgerald actually uses
the word "tragedy." "The 'death
car,' as the newspapers
called it, didn't stop.
It came out of the gathering
darkness, wavered tragically
for a moment, and then
disappeared around the next
bend." We know that this is the
moment when Myrtle gets
killed, and of course,
she's-- sorry.
The book doesn't really rest
on that one detail.
You can know it and
still think it's a
great novel to read.
But this is what happens
to Myrtle.
And in some sense, there's
an echoing already.
There was a dead man in a
hearse in that previous
passage about an automobile.
And in this passage, that
was just a completely
inconspicuous reference
that it just
happened to be a hearse.
In the second mention of the
car, it actually is a real
hearse, not in the sense that
there's a dead body in it, but
in the sense that it's the
carrier of death, it's the
bringer, conveyor, of
death to Myrtle.
So we can get a sense of what a
careful writer Fitzgerald is
right here.
He's someone who works over
details over and over again so
that there're all
these intricate
interconnections in the novel.
And in that way, even though it
is every bit as complicated
as Faulkner, it's not as
difficult to read on the face
of it as Faulkner.
But it's a novel that we should
read over and over
again as well just to get
all those echoes and
interrelations.
So we'll come back on Thursday
and wrap up The Great Gatsby.